[Musik]
dies ist der Pilatus in Luzern in der
Schweiz
vor über 100 Jahren entwickelten
wagemutige Unternehmer revolutionäre
Technologie für eine Zahnradbahn auf den
Gipfel des Berges
noch heute ist sie die steilste Bahn
ihrer Art der Welt
[Musik]
der Aufstieg dauerte zu Fuß und auf Last
Eseln einen Tag nun war er möglich in
weniger als 40 Minuten
dies machte den Pilatus weltberühmt
etwas ähnliches spielt sich nun erneut
ab
fintech Unternehmer entwickeln neue
Technologie und Software um
bankenddienstleistungen einfacher
günstiger und bequemer zu machen
zusammen mit den Schweizer Banken
möchten Sie den Finanzplatz ins digitale
Zeitalter bringen
ich bin Schweizer und Unternehmer meinen
ersten Start-up gründete ich 1996 in der
Schweiz und danach weitere Firmen in
Amerika und Japan ich habe Bücher über
Finance und Unternehmertum geschrieben
das bankenland Schweiz und fintech
ziehen sich offensichtlich an es gibt
aber auch andere Voraussetzungen hier
als im Ausland um einen besseren
Überblick über fintech in der Schweiz zu
erhalten besuchte ich Unternehmer
Investoren bonkeys und Politiker mit
ihnen sprach ich über ihre Erfahrungen
Herausforderungen und Wünsche für
fintech made in Switzerland
[Musik]
ich glaube die erste
dass man Technologie jetzt kann
gewinnbringend und da auch disruptiv
Finanzwelt bringen
was gibt es eigentlich auf der
technologischen Seite und wie kann man
das Gesetz
of doing things get reduce
things becomes
bestehende
Finanzdienstleister
das gab wesentlich weiter zum
Digitalisierung und weniger dass man
vorne sieht sondern um das ganz große
Thema und wie gesagt
wertschöpfungsindustrie werden
aber es ist einfach so vereinfachen oder
mit Druck auf den Knopf das Taxi kommt
das ganze Prozess und ich glaube es bis
sehr viel mehr von der Banken
sind am Schluss einfach unsere Hunde
Sicht sehr sehr viel einfacher wir
können dem Grund direkt
zu verwirk stellen und
Unterschied das ist nicht so dass man
neu Business modal kreiert und Moment
aber der Kunde ist nicht bereits
schnell zu spektakulär aber ich glaube
wenn man eine beschrieben hätte ich
mit oberstaxi Wesen kann kann optimieren
empfundenes
if you have been to the taxi business on
a long comes uber
digitalisieren also banks digitalisieren
wesentlich einfacher aber Technologie
ist jetzt soweit dass das was kann also
wird sie sagen alles war richtig
Effizienz kann optimiert werden und also
effektiv oder Effektivität optimierte
die Geschichte von Ökonomie das wird
auch im stark regulierten finanzmarktsee
natürlich
auf der anderen Seite können wir auch
wieder viel gut machen man darf auch
wieder der Mensch ist Zentrum setzen und
da ist überlege Technologie benutzen ums
Finanzwesen Finanzmärkte wieder zum
benefit von der Lüth Umwandler schaffen
dann haben wir raus Ziel erreichten da
machen wir aber auch viel Geld und dann
macht es auch wirklich Spaß weil dann
haben wir ein bisschen
produzieren mit dem aber auch
drauf spielen und die Chance dass man
einfach
und die freut mich am Gestalten ich
glaube das ist das wo man nur vermisst
das wird mir gefallen
hat das ja eigentlich sehr sehr gut
funktioniert dass man wirklich gesagt
hat das Zentrum wenn man Technologie
nutzen um Hund quasi Lösungen
funktioniert und Gesetz nicht wieso
werden wir der Weg wieder beschreitet
wieder
s and where you can significent the
improve the lives of May wiederhole
of the world population
[Musik]
zum 30
reduzieren zum Vertrag fürs altersvorsor
zu verbessern es hat noch nie wenn man
mir sieht man die zweite wahlkrieg in
deren Industrie so viel Chance
Industrie und wird aktuell
Finanzindustrie ist es die beste Zeit
der industriezeit
im Studium das heißt die letzten zwei
Jahre im
Unternehmertum unterwegs haben jetzt die
zweitfirma wo ich mit aufbaue
in the street because there is a lot of
trust going to a into the street
Versicherung was wir bei Knip gemacht
haben weder Dennis noch ich hatten
irgendeine Ahnung von Versicherung wir
sind eigentlich so gestartet dass wir
gesagt haben wir denken Knip aus
Kundensicht und das war glaube ich am
Ende dann das auch das Erfolgsgeheimnis
für unsere Idee weil wir einfach nicht
diese Versicherungs denke auch von den
Prozessen her hatten und wie man das
schon immer gemacht hat sondern wir
haben digitales Wissen auf die Ver
regierungswelt angewendet
beschrieb von
traditionellen Bank
in der fintech waldinen ist eigentlich
nicht sondern grosser Schritt sie will
finance was spannend
mit der Technologie mich Differenz
okay Produkt lohnt sich verkaufen
und das Team glauben und hängt den
gemeinsam das ganze Luft baut und wie
auch entzieht die letzte zweieinhalb
Jahren
ich war von Endorphinen ja aber
andererseits wenn man als Gründer und
als Unternehmer in sowas drin ist man
lässt das natürlich sehr nah an sich ran
ja also das ist mein lebt das ja
Unternehmer sie heißt nicht nur viel
Risiken
oder der Unternehmer ehrlich
darstellen in der Schweiz Kultur von der
Bank ist definitiv weg komplett andere
als jetzt von meiner dreijährige text
in the fintext wear and that was also
keine
companies are here and the would like to
can a out compete banks open extendeers
Banking
der Prozessor
für für Bank vermutlich recht schnell
früh
das ist wirklich das wirklich in
Meilensteins im frühjahrsfirma aber ich
denke auch für die gemeinsame Kunden
dass das verhebt dass ich erst die
Testmärkte kann erschliessen und du es
demosen entstanden natürlich die ganz
große Finanzierungsrunde kam das war
dann natürlich schon noch mal eine
andere Nummer auch als wir dann gesagt
haben wir internationalisieren nach
Deutschland zehnmal so groß wie die
Schweiz nach sehr kurzer Zeit das sind
natürlich alles riesen Meilensteine die
man die die wir glaube ich die auch das
Team
erst wirklich verarbeiten musste und die
Strukturen in so einer kleinen
Unternehmen man ist am Anfang zu zweit
auf einmal ist man zu zehn dann ist man
30 50 70 120 das war schon eine sehr
sehr große Herausforderung aber eine
tolle Herausforderung
[Musik]
was passiert mit dieser
normalgesetzbedarf als mattleder ist es
sehr schwierig zu wachsen im risikoarmer
machen Digitalisierung
muss aber sagen dass das gilt für euch
auch so unser Braut ist eigentlich von
der Credit Suisse uns einzubringen in
die relevanten Themen und schauen wie
wir diese Ideen der Startups für uns
einbinden können in unsere digitalen
offerings was mir sicher anders gemacht
hat ist dass man auf eine sehr starken
davon gemacht also das immer über das
sind sehr breit das sind Start-Ups das
sind wie Seas das sind Berater das sind
technologieprovider verschiedene
internetaffin zum Internet zum Hypothek
rein online digital abschließen
abzuwickeln und wir haben natürlich sehr
klar oder der Bus glaubt und
umso schöner ist
richtig durchgestartet ist das ist zum
Flaggschiff wurde online Produkt und
eine Tour das ist immer auf
rohrflüssigkeit
der Prozess ist doch etwas aufwendiger
wie sich das gemeinhin so von außen
einfach darstellt aber es sind sehr sage
ich mal kooperative und proaktive
Meetings die dort stattfinden man sucht
Lösungen die Status möchten unbedingt
natürlich es einbringen wir möchten
unbedingt innovativ sein sofern findet
man dann doch über viele Ecken dann die
Lösung Organisation Welt vor zwei
Geschwindigkeiten können
innerhalb von Konzernen zum Stabilität
gewährleisten aber nach außen wenn man
viel effizienter und viel schneller
werden insbesondere zwar mit einer
fintechunternehmen oder mit anderen
technounternehmen
diese Agilität und diese Mentalität die
die fintechs da mitbringen Sachen
auszuprobieren schnell zu sein
zu lernen auch neue Wege zu gehen weg
vom traditionell das muss ein
Unternehmen definitiv in Zukunft
mitbringen worum soll mich darum bin ich
besser
oder ich muss halt immer ein halber
Schritt fordern
was ist nächste was gefordert wird
zu schnell digital besser
gemacht hat
bilanzrechnung glaube ich nicht dass man
die Digitalisierung in der Schweiz
genannt wurdet oder dass mir
Veranstaltungen dürfen
ich würde eben stark davon abraten von
einer karnevalisierung zu sprechen es
ist komplementär ist eine
Weiterentwicklung von Modell und wer
sich nicht ändert der wird zum Schluss
das Nachsehen haben das heißt zu lange
festzuhalten an traditionellen
Geschäftsmodellen ist sehr gefährlich
auf der anderen Seite ist es auch
unnötig zu früh diese schon loszulassen
wie viel das auch muss man Basis machen
und dann werden
und dann
wow das ist wirklich in Summe oder
dieses Beispiel gesehen
und lustig
sehr sehr robusten Entwickler
[Musik]
wirklich das wird schweizwählen als eine
Frau finde ich Startups
etablieren und speziell im Bereich von
der Versicherung glaube ich ihren
absolut vier in die Urlauben
viel verpennt Konferenz vereint dem
Thema findet
dass man vielleicht auch im Regulator
kann entsprechende druckkurs über und
das ist eigentlich eine getriebene
klangkarte auf der sogenannte
finteklangkarte sehen
so extrem
fintech Startups anzieht es entsteht
extrem viel Modell aus der Schweiz
in der Schweizer grundsätzlich sehr gut
die Rahmenbedingungen
und London ist Firmen die dann über 100
Mitarbeiter haben gibt es ja im Startup
Bereich also sprich Firmen die dann
vielleicht erst ein zwei Jahre sind
nicht wahnsinnig viel wenn ich schaue
wie viele solche Unternehmen in London
oder oder in Berlin unterwegs sind dann
erschrickt man teilweise also die
stellen dann jeden Monat mehr Leute ein
als hier die Firmen vielleicht dann nach
drei vier Jahren total wir sind ein
kleines Land oder mehr in den seeren
Kindermarkt und Digitalgeschäft ist
primäres Masse geschafft oder das
skaliert mit Marktgröße und was uns
natürlich jetzt fehlt
insbesondere jetzt auch in dem fintech
Bereich dass wir wirklich aus der
Schweiz heraus Firmen haben die jetzt
nicht nur in der deutsch ganz
erfolgreich sind und dann als nächste
große Ambitionen in die Romandie gehen
und umgekehrt sondern dass wir wirklich
Firmen haben die sagen wir wollen Europa
Marktführer Weltmarktführer werden in
gewissen Bereichen das Thema
blindland is slightly more an reasonable
on to benasser
figurite
you you ich verstehe dass man in der
Schweiz keine keine Industriepolitik
historisch macht das ist Fakt das wird
mir immer so gesagt und das ist auch zu
akzeptieren die Frage ist einfach die
Welt dreht sich weiter und andere
Standorte machen Industriepolitik für
fintech was mir wirklich verhält ist
Gedanken
also ich allein sondern Eco ein bisschen
was mir gemeinsam auf gleicher Augenhöhe
und das fällt und dort müssen
damit sie der Schweizer wirklich
weitergeht das ist im mostland ganz
anders
das macht eigentlich der Druck oder für
die zusammenarbeiten
und da müsste man sich jetzt einfach mal
konsequent als Finanzplatz als Schweiz
dafür entscheiden insgesamt machen wir
das jetzt aber da fehlt es ein
Abstimmung es fehlt ein Koordination es
fehlt ein finanziellen Ressourcen man
glaubt dass es alles gut das ist einfach
nicht so und auch wenn man mit mit
Politikern spricht die meisten verstehen
überhaupt nicht was fintech ist
würden wichtige Beitrag leisten in der
sekundsystem und gross meine irgendwo
500 Millionen bis irgendwo also in deren
Kapital zur Verfügung stellt für die
sogenannte sicheres
größere Tickets für Schweizer startup-
ich bin der Meinung das Geld ist ja da
also aus Pensionskasse eigentlich fehlt
nur derjenige der das solche striert
schlussendlich so entstanden
wenn man eigentlich ja schon fast alle
Handwerker in Fabrik hat warum macht man
es nicht es ist für mich und das was
mich am meisten frustriert ist dass es
vergleichsweise wenig Geld bräuchte
warum steckt man das nicht in die jungen
Leute in Jungunternehmer die sich
wirklich in Arm und ein Bein rausreißen
um diese Arbeitsplätze zu schaffen und
das ist für mich eigentlich eben wenn
man nur ein Promille oder was weiß ich
wirklich Exo wenig in in so eine Art
Staatsform packen würde für die
Schweizer Jungunternehmer das ist mir
unerklärlich das verstehe ich nicht ich
glaube der Zug ist stört noch nicht
abgefahren
absolut Chance dass man das auch wieder
in der Schweiz könnte schaffe aber
the time sind my life when I have a
cheaped
myself in danger the
besting
and performance
Innovation immer immer Geschäftsumfeld
kommt aber nicht für ihn also
ich habe mir das geht immer ein aber
grundsätzlich kommt sie nicht von innen
oder Thema wie Crowdfunding oder wie
blockchain oder wie sharing economie
die liegt nicht offensichtlich
was kann man mit der blockchain machen
bringt es irgendwie besonders
ich Finanz und ich Technologie also es
ist ich finde dich gemäß Definition und
es ist aber abgrenzt von der fintech
Szene und ich habe mich oft gefragt
warum das ist und ein Möglichkeit ist
das Leben sehr ideologisch ist
Bitcoin machen oder sonst mit der
kryptowährung beschäftigt sind die
werden nicht einfacher Startup machen
zum
Geld verdienen oder ein guter
Businessplan realisieren sondern die
eventuell das Finanzsystem
revolutionieren es ist eminent wichtig
dass das Unternehmen Dören öffnet um
Ideen andere Geschäftsmodell anders
denken eigentlich eher Lotte früher
gestartet
und irgendwann sind wir zum Bunker warum
beschränkt man die Erreichung von den
ideene die Innovationen warum beschenken
mit ihr nochmal auf die eigenen
Scouting hätten wir noch relativ schnell
im Griff
schöne tolle Anzahl von Unternehmen
kontaktiert oder mehr hätte der gute
Idee möchte damit schaffen und terrus
erfolgreich
die nachhaltig Methode ist sage okay ab
und zu kretain alter beim Umwelt und
dafür wachsen viele junge Bäume und die
größte Gefahr ist verhindert dass junge
Bäume erwachsen können also wenn man zum
Beispiel viel
regulierig Macht so dass Fixkosten
der Weg ist viele Klinik Experimente
immer wieder versuchen und etwas gut
geht entwickelt man sich weiter und so
und so kann man nicht
wo man nachher vielleicht neue Trikot
generieren
aber so der endgroße Sprung und nachher
landen
2026 und übrigens
wäre mir den Themen haben wo man hat
nicht auf dem Rad
halten und ja sich entwickeln und
irgendwen
zu machen um die Tiere damit die
richtige
passierend auf der neue Technologien und
vor allem auf der blockchainer
Technologie fundamentale veränderliche
Welt haben wir heute einfach noch nicht
genau ein abschätze insbesondere im
Internet dazugeschäft also
überall wo mehr Hüte
intermeditationsleistungen
wo eigentlich könnte digital ersetzt
werden
Digitalisierung
aber für fast alle andere Bereiche haben
die mittlerweile vorstelliger wie ja die
Digitalisierung und das wird tatsächlich
fundamentale Veränderungen
auf dem blockchain oder ich gründe
digital Entwicklungsphase
aber das ist schon wirklich dass man das
zum Teil bitte der Geist fehlt zum
einfach Giga und mache
es geht tolle fintechunternehmen in dem
Land nicht so viel aber tolle budener
Kantonalbank mit Verbund vor
Regionalbanken
Mehrwert generieren und das ist auch das
schönes Bild das ist nämlich die
traditionelle Bank was sie 150 Jahren
wirkliches Problem kann lösen
und das sind die Unternehmungen
der Standort Zürich dass mir auch die
ganz technologisch entwickelt Nutzen im
Finanzbereich und da auch neue Ideen
können noch danken und neue Ideen wo der
Finanzmarkt wo wir ja eh schon sind im
Kanton Zürich eben wieder stärken die
Art und Weise wo wir in der Schweiz
schon normal auch gewachsen speziell und
gehört für das
schnalz
das ist nicht kurz auf Singapur und dann
wieder auf New York das eine
Verlängerung
und meine
Welt mit dem Blackrock wo ich
strategisch
extrem viel tolle Brands mit extrem viel
Know-how ich bin eben vor drei Jahren in
die Schweiz gekommen ich habe dann Knip
gegründet ich habe mit den Jungs SFS
gegründet und ich wurde unglaublich
herzlich aufgenommen und das ist glaube
ich nicht selbstverständlich und das ist
auch das was ich der Schweiz wirklich
sehr hoch anrechne ich führen Westerland
to found that you were Station
identity genial bis ins Land von der
Menschenrecht wir sind neutral politisch
stabil perfekt für globale Lösung
etablierte Bank zu welchem
Prozentsatz und egal ob alt oder jung
und egal welche Schicht das Vertrauen in
die Banken versichern mich heute noch
gewaltig grosse müssen Schaffens
Geschäftsmodell zu entwickeln
Unterstützung
das 8 millionenland hätten Finn
technology Leuchtturm entwickelt wo
davor zingerpool liegt schwärmen die in
London Lugert mit glänziger Augen auf
schwitzen sagen
hoffe das klingt euch braucht ja wieder
als die reine Finanzbranche es betrifft
der Versicherungsbranche es gibt erneut
Branche wo sich entwickeln wo mir
vielleicht
vorstellen wo mich heute werden ich
glaube dass es in der Schweiz extrem
gute Talente hat ich glaube wir auch
gerade von der Historie her haben wir
wissen und und Reputation die man
unbedingt nutzen muss aus meiner Sicht
geht es darum jetzt finance in fintech
zu transformieren also dass man guckt
wie bekommen wir dieses Finanzwissen das
noch da ist die Leute sind hier noch die
kriegt man das transformiert in die in
die Zukunft in die digitale Welt sie
schaut schon so mir Handeln in der
Schweiz und das ist schauen Kanton
Zürich
Innovationskraft und das sind da sie
stärkeren und seine Stärken es immer gut
aber damit
kommt immer wieder im Pflege und man hat
die Chance ich bleib sehr Drama das für
Hanna ein rollerspieler auf dem Markt in
den Waden damit
Schweizer wäre
sind mutig werden Unternehmer oder
Unternehmer
und nicht von der Gesellschaft
entmutigen
dann hat man dort mehr Gründer das heißt
eine Ökosystem entsteht und wenn der
Gründer sind dann kommen die Investoren
und wenn der Gründer und Investoren sind
dann kommen vielleicht auch die
Innovation Labs von den großen
Unternehmen sie sehen eine UBS mit dem
Level seit hinein in London ja und dann
entsteht da einfach so ein Strudel den
man auch gar nicht mehr aufhalten kann
to finance
und das ist ja echt schön aber wenn dir
nicht sehr risikofreudig sieben wenn
einfach ein bisschen weniger Risiko
werden
financing maybe the business around the
block Brother than yes
Community Möglichkeit mit mit
innovationsfreundlichen oder freudige
Kunden und Partner ganz neue Sachen zu
entwickeln also noch wahnsinnig viel
Spaß es ist super Zeit da wünsche ich
mir dass man wirklich gemeinsam an dem
Schweizer Filmtechnik
einerseitsystem zwischen Bank und
Startups das machen viel aber es geht
auch um
Zusammenarbeiten zwischen Bank selber
nicht miteinander oder nicht die eigene
Interesse zu
was braucht der Finanzplatz als wir da
große miteinander
diese Gemeinsamkeit die die Schweiz hier
jetzt zu Tage trägt ist einmalig und
setzt sich auch ab in der Welt und das
ist sehr sehr positiv aber es mal
Kooperation sind stark drin
[Musik]